Musique calme
-Il faudra modifier la Constitution.
Je demanderai aux Français
de se prononcer.
-Sont-ils d'accord
avec le regroupement familial ?
-Le président doit venir
à des méthodes plus démocratiques.
-Une fois élue,
je réhabiliterai le référendum !
-Le référendum est une promesse
de campagne présidentielle.
-Cela montre le fait
que les politiques sont déboussolés.
-Depuis 2005,
il n'y a plus de référendum.
-Le référendum semble aujourd'hui
faire l'unanimité.
Pourtant, depuis 2005,
aucun président n'y a eu recours.
-Restaurer un usage massif
du référendum.
-Le référendum,
c'est un grand moment de sincérité,
le président et le peuple.
-Oui, non.
C'est binaire, spectaculaire.
-Constitutionnellement,
elle doit d'abord passer
par l'Assemblée puis le Sénat.
-Quel est donc
l'avenir du référendum ?
Cet outil démocratique
est-il difficile à manier ?
Et le pari politique
parfois trop risqué ?
-La classe politique française
reste assez traumatisée
par l'échec du référendum de 2005.
-Ca a engendré
une profonde turbulence politique.
-Le moment fondateur
de ce qui se passe
dans notre vie politique depuis.
-Je préfère
une consultation populaire
à un blocage du pays.
...
-10 référendums ont été organisés
depuis 1958.
De Gaulle, qui veut avoir
un lien direct avec les Français,
fera de cette consultation populaire
une arme politique majeure.
A cinq reprises,
il interrogera le peuple
sur des décisions essentielles
qui engagent l'avenir du pays.
Moins de quatre mois
après son retour au pouvoir,
c'est par un référendum
que le général de Gaulle
va faire adopter
la nouvelle Constitution.
-Le 4 septembre 1958,
le général de Gaulle soumettait
au peuple français
la Constitution
qui allait devenir
l'acte de naissance
et la charte de la Ve République.
-C'est sur la très symbolique
place de la République
qu'il présente son projet.
-C'est dans la légalité
que moi-même et mon gouvernement
avons assumé...
Acclamations
...Avons assumé
le mandat exceptionnel
d'établir un projet
de Constitution nouvelle
et de le soumettre
à la décision du peuple.
Nous l'avons fait.
-L'exécutif est renforcé.
Le président sera désormais
la véritable clé de voûte
des institutions.
Tel est l'esprit du projet proposé
aux Français.
-La grande méfiance du général,
en 1958,
mais dès 1946 en réalité,
c'est une méfiance
à l'égard des parlementaires.
A travers sa méfiance
à leur égard,
c'est une méfiance
à l'égard des partis politiques.
Le chef de l'Etat
doit être au-dessus
des contingences
et des partis.
-Pour le général,
il y a l'Etat d'un côté,
l'Etat qui a un chef, lui,
et le peuple.
C'est les deux pôles essentiels.
Il faut donc que le chef de l'Etat,
régulièrement,
demande l'avis du peuple.
-Au nom de la France,
je vous demande de répondre "Oui" !
La foule crie "Oui".
-Pendant qu'il parlait,
la place était très surveillée,
mais derrière,
dans les rues adjacentes,
il y avait
des opposants, en milliers.
Protestations de la foule
-Les adversaires de la Constitution
en 1958,
ils sont
principalement hostiles
à ce qui apparaît
comme une figure présidentielle
potentiellement
extrêmement forte.
La crainte
du monarque républicain.
Musique grave
...
-Oran, dès l'ouverture du scrutin,
se pressait devant les urnes.
L'Algérie votait à 83 %.
Fernandel s'enfermait
dans le secret à Marseille.
Musique enlevée
Et Yves Montand votait
par correspondance à Lyon.
...
A 10h du soir,
les dernières urnes s'ouvraient.
...
Au ministère de l'Intérieur,
un immense tableau comptabilisait
les résultats, sous les yeux
de messieurs Soustelle et Malraux.
-Oui à 80 % pour la métropole,
à 97 % pour...
-Le plus important
de tous les référendums
qui ont eu lieu
sous la Ve République,
c'est le premier,
celui qui a permis
de tout changer.
C'est à l'usage qu'il s'est aperçu
que c'était
un instrument de gouvernement,
et notamment
lors de la guerre d'Algérie.
*Musique trépidante
-C'est une journée inoubliable
que vient de vivre Alger.
-Mettre un terme
au conflit algérien,
c'est une priorité absolue
pour de Gaulle,
dès son retour au pouvoir.
Pour y parvenir, il organisera
deux référendums en 15 mois.
En janvier 1961,
puis en avril 1962.
...
-Les Français étaient lassés
de voir leurs enfants
mourir en Algérie.
De Gaulle le sentait.
Ces référendums,
c'était le moyen de consacrer
par un vote populaire
la politique qu'il menait,
et de la consacrer
contre les ultras.
-Il fallait conduire progressivement
une opinion publique qui,
sous la IVe, s'était,
pour une bonne part,
ralliée à l'idée du maintien
de l'Algérie française,
la conduire vers l'idée
de l'autodétermination
et de l'indépendance.
-Il a besoin,
pour mener sa politique algérienne
qui marque tout de même
un changement de cap
par rapport aux positions
qu'il avait adoptées en 1958,
il avait besoin
du soutien populaire.
-Françaises, Français,
nous voulons que 1961
soit l'année de la paix rétablie.
-Ce problème d'Algérie
altérait terriblement
la vie politique française.
Il fallait s'en débarrasser vite.
La peuple l'a compris.
-Pourquoi faut-il voter ?
-C'est le devoir de tout le monde.
On a certainement
tous quelqu'un en Algérie,
moi, j'ai mon frère, et c'est normal
qu'on essaie de faire quelque chose.
-Comme ça fait 20 ans qu'on se sert
de de Gaulle comme guide,
et qu'on est heureux de le voir
dans les bonnes circonstances,
eh bien dans les mauvaises
ou dans les moins bonnes,
on est avec lui,
on vote oui avec lui.
-Je sais qu'on doit voter
pour de Gaulle
quand on veut voter pour la paix,
mais exactement quoi...
-Vous votez en confiance ?
-Voilà.
-Ca permet d'aller plus vite,
parce qu'alors même
qu'il y avait toujours
des oppositions
dans la représentation
parlementaire,
l'organisation d'un référendum
rend incontestable
l'action du général de Gaulle.
Musique majestueuse
...
-En vérité,
ces 2 moments
ont été fondamentaux.
Ils lui ont redonné
une légitimité
dans ce qui était une politique
très difficile à conduire,
compte tenu de la violence
des passions,
de la dimension de l'enjeu.
-L'heure de l'apaisement
arrive-t-elle enfin ?
L'heure de l'apaisement
avec l'heure de l'espérance.
Une espérance que chaque Français
va fixer avec le bulletin
qu'il glissera dans l'urne.
...
-Le fait que 90 % des Français
approuvent
le référendum d'indépendance
de l'Algérie en avril 62,
c'est extraordinaire,
parce que ça transforme
ce qui pourrait paraître
comme un échec formidable,
la France doit quitter l'Algérie,
en victoire.
C'est la victoire de la France.
-La journée du 8 avril 1962
a créé une situation irréversible
en Algérie,
d'une importance exceptionnelle
dans l'histoire de la République.
-De Gaulle vieillissait,
il sentait bien
que la guerre d'Algérie terminée
se poserait la question
de l'après lui.
Musique dramatique
-Presque un an après l'attentat OAS
qui l'avait visé,
le général de Gaulle a encore
servi de cible à ses adversaires.
Musique intrigante
-Un groupe fanatique,
qui le haïssait
pour avoir fait la paix en Algérie,
s'en est pris à sa personne,
et le hasard a fait que de Gaulle
a survécu,
et du même coup,
il a souhaité tirer parti
de cet événement
pour expliquer au peuple
qu'à n'importe quel moment,
la vacance du pouvoir,
la vacance à l'Elysée
pouvait intervenir,
et qu'il fallait se préparer.
-Quand sera terminé
mon propre septennat,
ou, si la mort
ou la maladie
l'interrompaient
avant le terme...
-Le général de Gaulle
a profité quand même de l'événement
pour faire prendre conscience
aux Français
qu'il pouvait disparaître
du jour au lendemain.
Qu'est-ce qui se passerait,
à ce moment-là ?
-Il sait qu'il n'est pas éternel,
et qu'après lui,
aucun homme politique
n'aura la légitimité historique
qui est la sienne.
Donc, il aura besoin de quoi,
le prochain président
ou la prochaine présidente ?
Il aura besoin
d'une légitimité démocratique
qui est celle de l'élection
d'un président
par le suffrage universel.
-Il avait cette idée
depuis très longtemps.
Sans doute avait-il hâte
de pouvoir la mettre en oeuvre,
néanmoins,
l'attentat du Petit-Clamart
lui offre presque
une occasion inespérée.
-L'attentat du Petit-Clamart
l'a décidé à passer à l'action.
De Gaulle était un stratège.
Il a senti que c'était le moment.
-Le président de la République
sera dorénavant élu
au suffrage universel.
-Le général annonce
qu'il va y avoir ce référendum
et l'Assemblée nationale vote
une motion de censure,
la seule votée
de toute la Ve République,
qui renverse le gouvernement.
-Allez dire à l'Elysée
que notre admiration
pour le passé est intacte,
mais que cette Assemblée
n'est pas assez dégénérée
pour renier la République.
-C'est ça !
"Nous ne sommes pas dégénérés.
La République est au Parlement,
"c'est le Parlement qui est
le fondement de la République."
C'est tout ce débat, derrière.
-Le référendum,
c'était un instrument
qui avait été utilisé
sous l'empire,
le plébiscite.
Donc, ça avait
un parfum de césarisme.
-Parce qu'au fond,
depuis la 2nde République,
qui avait vu l'élection
du prince Louis-Napoléon Bonaparte,
puis le coup d'Etat,
dans la culture démocratique
française,
on se disait
qu'il fallait éviter
l'élection par le peuple,
puisque c'est celle d'un séditieux.
-Si cette discussion nous amène
à nous opposer, eh bien,
comme il est naturel,
le pays tranchera.
-De Gaulle choisit,
avec l'article 11,
de contourner le Parlement,
de poser la question directement
aux Français,
plutôt que d'utiliser l'article 89,
qui impose de passer d'abord
par les deux assemblées
pour réviser la Constitution.
Cette décision va provoquer
un violent débat juridique
et politique.
-Evidemment,
pour les hommes politiques
de la IIIe République,
c'est une déclaration de guerre,
et qui s'appuie...
Ils insistent tous, évidemment,
sur la violation de la Constitution.
-De Gaulle n'a pas soumis
ce projet de référendum
à l'Assemblée nationale
comme, en principe,
il aurait dû le faire.
Il est allé à sa manière.
-Je ne sais pas
si de Gaulle s'est dit
qu'il violait la Constitution.
Il s'est dit :
"Finalement, je vais passer par là,
"parce que mon objectif,
c'est que cette réforme aboutisse,
"et c'est le seul chemin qui est
à ma disposition pour le faire."
-A la fin des années 60,
nos professeurs
de droit constitutionnel
nous abreuvaient de ce débat.
Je me souviens
d'hommes extrêmement respectables
qui, en chaire,
tenaient des propos
d'un antigaullisme
absolument hallucinant.
Sur ce thème,
il n'avait pas le droit
d'utiliser l'article 11
pour réformer la Constitution,
puisqu'il y a un article dédié,
l'article 89.
-Nul ne peut douter que
s'il s'en était tenu à l'article 89,
compte tenu de l'état d'esprit
des deux chambres,
il n'aurait pas abouti
à cette solution.
Disons en tout cas
que de Gaulle a dit
à des interlocuteurs :
"On peut me critiquer,
mais cette Constitution,
"je la connais,
c'est moi qui l'ai faite."
-Chaque oui
de chacune de celles,
de chacun de ceux
qui me l'aura donné
me sera la preuve directe
de sa confiance
et de son encouragement.
-Et là, voilà, en quelques phrases,
en quelques mots,
il va convaincre les Français,
le pouvoir législatif
n'aura qu'à plier les genoux.
-Personne ne se risquerait
aujourd'hui
à faire ce qu'il a fait à l'époque.
C'était de Gaulle,
c'était une autre époque,
mais c'est un coup de force.
-Les rotatives débitent
les planches de oui et de non.
Oui ou non,
le président de la République
sera-t-il élu
par tous les citoyens ?
Si la réponse est positive,
elle changera la vie politique.
-En réalité, ce n'est pas tant
la procédure qu'on lui reproche,
en 1962, ce qu'on lui reproche,
c'est l'objet de la réforme,
parce que chacun est bien conscient
qu'en décidant qu'à l'avenir,
le président de la République
sera élu
au suffrage universel direct,
eh bien le président ainsi élu
aura une légitimité extraordinaire.
Et cette légitimité extraordinaire
risque de faire basculer le régime
vers une monarchie
constitutionnelle,
un régime
résolument présidentialiste.
-Voici le général de Gaulle
confirmé au pouvoir
à une heure où une crise aurait eu
de fatales conséquences.
Musique élégante
...
-Certains juristes,
même ceux qui avaient critiqué
la procédure, disent qu'après coup,
le fait même du oui massif
à cette proposition
avait en quelque sorte
rétroactivement validé le principe.
-A partir de 1962,
tout change.
Tout change d'abord
en termes de légitimité
de la figure du président,
on retourne
et on dépasse un interdit
dans la culture politique française,
cet interdit,
c'était que le président
soit élu par le peuple.
-En 62, il décide
qu'on a changé d'époque
et on change de régime,
mais après 68,
il sait qu'une autre époque
se dessine.
-Après plusieurs villes
aussi différentes que Rome,
Berlin-ouest ou Varsovie,
l'agitation étudiante
s'est manifestée à Paris.
Détonations
-Mai 1968 embrase la France.
Le pays est paralysé,
le pouvoir violemment contesté.
De Gaulle est surpris
et bousculé
par cette révolte.
-Françaises et Français,
avec l'accord du président
de la République,
qui s'adressera à vous
dans quelques jours,
j'ai rendu l'université
à ses maîtres et à ses étudiants.
-Le référendum de 69,
c'est d'abord, pour de Gaulle,
la conséquence de mai 68
et de juin 68.
"10 ans, ça suffit",
clamaient les manifestants.
-Le typhon de l'émeute est passé
et la France entière,
paralysée,
en a été bouleversée.
-En juin, la majorité gaulliste
remporte largement les élections
législatives anticipées,
mais le général veut regagner
la confiance des Français.
Alors, une nouvelle fois,
il organise un référendum
avec deux questions :
l'une sur la régionalisation,
l'autre sur la réforme du Sénat.
-Il se trouve que j'étais à Quimper
le jour où le général
a proposé ce référendum.
-Nous devons soumettre
le projet au peuple.
-Je revois encore la scène
où il était
sur la place de Quimper,
sur le petit tertre.
Il y avait des gens en fureur,
des tas de manifestations,
et ça, on l'a oublié.
On a gardé du général de Gaulle
une certaine image,
une image d'unité nationale.
-Dans l'immense transformation...
-A partir de 68,
il était détesté.
Il l'était déjà un peu avant,
mais j'ai ressenti personnellement
un désir de se débarrasser
du général.
-Le général de Gaulle
sentait très bien
qu'il y avait une usure.
Une usure à son égard.
Il était suffisamment lucide.
Il voulait certainement vérifier
si cette usure était profonde,
était réelle,
même vis-à-vis d'un vieux président
de la République,
qui jouait le jeu de la réforme.
-Comme le général de Gaulle
appuie toute sa présidence
sur le rapport au peuple,
il juge nécessaire
de remettre en jeu cette légitimité.
-De la réponse que le pays fera
à ce que je lui demande
va dépendre évidemment
soit la continuation de mon mandat
soit, aussitôt, mon départ.
-C'est un référendum très gaullien,
au sens où comme en 1962,
mais d'une manière
beaucoup plus éclatante,
il met son mandat dans la balance,
et donc, il dit très clairement
aux électeurs
qui vont avoir à répondre
par oui ou par non
que si le non l'emporte,
il partira.
-Notre parti appelle
les Françaises
et les Français à répondre non !
-Ce référendum est immoral.
Comment voulez-vous répondre
par une seule réponse, oui ou non,
à plusieurs questions différentes ?
-Il faut pas oublier que Mitterrand,
dans un livre,
le comparait à Franco,
et même à Hitler.
Donc, ça allait quand même
très loin.
-La campagne des gaullistes
est difficile.
Le général est âgé de 77 ans,
et, pour beaucoup de Français,
Georges Pompidou apparaît
comme le dauphin naturel.
-Tout cet électorat sait
que Pompidou,
qui a montré
des qualités indéniables
pendant mai 68,
va prendre le relais,
donc, l'élément de dramatisation
que le général veut introduire
en posant la question de confiance
disparaît un peu.
-Quant à Valéry Giscard d'Estaing,
il prend clairement ses distances
avec de Gaulle
et avec le projet
soumis au référendum.
-Avec regret,
mais avec certitude,
je ne l'approuverai pas.
-C'est une manière assez élégante
de le dire.
Il ne dit pas "je voterai non",
il ne dit pas "je voterai contre",
il dit "je ne l'approuverai pas",
avec son style particulier.
-Valéry Giscard d'Estaing a fait
cette déclaration,
en prenant ses distances nettement
avec les intentions du général,
maintenant, il a toujours soutenu,
jusqu'à la fin de sa vie,
qu'il n'avait pas voté non,
qu'il avait voté blanc.
-Si je suis désavoué
par une majorité d'entre vous,
je cesserai aussitôt
d'exercer mes fonctions.
-Ca résume la Ve République :
c'est un homme qui est là
parce que les Français l'ont décidé,
et les Français peuvent décider
de le retirer, de le révoquer,
et d'une façon constitutionnelle.
Il a poussé l'exercice référendaire,
la cérémonie référendaire,
vraiment jusqu'à l'ultime.
-Et puis la réponse du peuple sera :
"Oui, le pouvoir est usé."
Ca faisait en effet plus de 10 ans
que le général de Gaulle
était au pouvoir,
et c'est un référendum
qui s'est conclu par le non.
-Mesdames, messieurs,
le projet de loi référendaire
n'est pas adopté.
Pour ma part,
si vous me permettez ici
de donner une note personnelle,
j'éprouve une grande tristesse
en songeant au départ
de celui qui demeure,
plus que jamais,
le plus illustre des Français.
-Le matin, je me demandais
si la Terre allait tourner
normalement.
Je me rappelle,
je suis sortie dans la rue
presque en ayant peur,
en me disant...
Il me semblait
que le grand parapluie de de Gaulle
était fini.
-Cette dimension tragique,
ou en tout cas de profondeur,
nous manque aujourd'hui
dans le débat politique français,
c'est quelque chose
de shakespearien.
*-Les grands titres
de la presse new-yorkaise,
les voici :
"De Gaulle, le dernier jour",
"De Gaulle quitte"...
-Les Allemands disent
que c'est considérable.
Ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi
le général de Gaulle a mis en jeu
ses fonctions présidentielles.
-S'en aller à la suite
d'un référendum perdu,
ça authentifiait
tout son parcours démocratique,
ça montrait qu'il avait lui aussi
une conception de la démocratie.
Mais quand même,
il en a beaucoup souffert.
C'était le dernier volet,
finalement, de son oeuvre.
-DE GAULLE, POMPIDOU !
DE GAULLE, POMPIDOU !
-Au nom du Conseil constitutionnel,
j'ai eu l'honneur de proclamer
Georges Pompidou président
de la République française.
-J'ai eu le privilège de déjeuner
à Colombey
à la fin de décembre 1969,
j'accompagnais mon père,
que de Gaulle
avait souhaité inviter.
J'en ai gardé le souvenir
d'un homme d'une grande sérénité.
On a évoqué ce qui allait être
le sujet du référendum suivant,
c'est-à-dire l'entrée possible
du Royaume-Uni
dans la Communauté Européenne.
Il pensait que l'Angleterre
n'était pas mûre
pour contribuer à la naissance
d'une identité européenne.
Donc, nous lui avons demandé
s'il pensait
que Pompidou continuerait
dans cette ligne,
à refuser l'entrée.
Il nous a dit :
"Non, non, il ne résistera pas."
Musique solennelle
...
-Faut-il ouvrir
les portes de l'Europe
à quatre nouveaux pays,
dont l'Angleterre ?
J'affirme que oui.
-De Gaulle avait été très clair
sur son opposition à l'entrée
du Royaume-Uni dans l'Europe.
Pour le dédire,
peut-être fallait-il un référendum.
-Au fond,
c'était sa 1re liberté, de se dire :
"C'est quand même impensable
"que l'Angleterre
ne fasse pas partie de l'Europe."
-Il y a aussi la volonté
de donner un visage plus ouvert
que le général de Gaulle
vis-à-vis de la question européenne
et de l'entrée de nouveaux acteurs
dans l'Europe.
Musique grave
...
-Il s'agit de savoir
si on élargit ou pas.
C'est une vraie transformation :
6 à 10, c'est presque le doublement
des membres,
et c'est le premier élargissement.
-A l'époque,
l'entrée de la Grande-Bretagne
dans le marché commun était
largement approuvée par l'opinion.
C'était tentant, évidemment,
de poser la question,
avec l'idée
qu'on ne risquait rien.
-Quelle est votre opinion
sur ce référendum ?
-De la part du président Pompidou,
c'est sensationnel.
Ca pose une sorte de piège,
suivant ce qu'on dit.
-Je suis pas d'accord.
C'est la division de la gauche.
-C'est le chef de l'Etat,
il a qu'à faire ce qui lui plaît
sans, à chaque instant,
consulter les électeurs.
Hein ?
-Après de Gaulle,
le référendum change.
Il y a une conception
assez politique
du référendum qui est intervenue :
le référendum est devenu
un outil politique,
quand il a été utilisé,
souvent pour diviser l'opposition.
Les socialistes et les communistes
discutaient
du programme commun
qui allait être signé en juin 1972.
Le référendum intervient
en avril 72.
-Le sens de nos affiches,
c'est d'inviter la population
à refuser de jouer
avec les tricheurs,
à refuser de voter
le 23 avril.
-Il y a un calcul politique
que Mitterrand tente de résoudre
en appelant à l'abstention
pour éviter un oui à Pompidou
qui aurait consisté
à casser les négociations
avec le PC.
-En disant non tous ensemble,
vous avez le moyen,
le seul moyen,
de porter un coup efficace
contre le gouvernement
de monsieur Pompidou.
-Vous ne trouverez pas
de bulletins blancs.
Alors, il vous restera
soit à le préparer chez vous,
bulletin blanc,
soit à vous abstenir,
soit à faire comme cela :
rayer l'un des bulletins.
-Il y a un appel très fort
à l'abstention dans l'opposition,
au référendum
et à Pompidou.
C'est un peu le piège dans lequel
Pompidou tombe malgré lui.
-Monsieur le président...
-A voté !
-Marchais, Georges.
-A ce moment se font
tous les calculs qui permettront,
à partir de 300 bureaux de vote,
de savoir comment les Français
ont voté.
-Les Français
ont ratifié l'entrée
des 4 candidats
dans le marché commun.
Les résultats ont toutefois déçu
les partenaires de la France,
du fait des abstentions.
-Le oui l'emporte sans problème,
mais la mobilisation est moindre.
On voit, au fond,
que la passion
qu'il y avait autour de la confiance
ayant disparu,
les Français vont montrer
un engouement
plus modéré
vis-à-vis du référendum.
-On a le sentiment que les Français
ne s'intéressent plus vraiment
à l'enjeu référendaire.
Musique intrigante
Ni Valéry Giscard d'Estaing,
ni François Mitterrand,
dans son premier mandat,
ne recourent au référendum.
...
Tic-tac d'horloge
-Retour à Matignon,
pour la passation des pouvoirs
entre Chirac et Rocard.
-Elle devait durer quelques minutes,
elle en aura duré 30.
Michel Rocard raccompagne
Jacques Chirac.
-Le référendum de 88,
c'est un référendum Rocard,
on peut le dire,
mais accepté par Mitterrand.
Il s'agit de rétablir la paix civile
en Nouvelle-Calédonie,
alors qu'il y a eu
des drames épouvantables auparavant,
dont celui de la grotte d'Ouvéa,
au moment de la campagne de 88.
-Mesdames et messieurs
les députés,
pas un jour ne s'est achevé
sans que mon action
et mes pensées
ne soient
pour la Nouvelle-Calédonie.
-François Mitterrand
confie à Michel Rocard,
quand il arrive à Matignon,
ce sujet qu'il connaît peu.
Michel Rocard
va se donner corps et âme,
jusqu'à passer
des nuits de négociations,
pour qu'on arrive
aux accords de Matignon,
puis au référendum.
-L'image que l'on croyait impossible
il y a quelques semaines,
cette poignée de mains,
avant une adresse aux Calédoniens.
-Reprenez espoir !
Une page nouvelle
va pouvoir s'écrire.
-Malheureusement,
ce référendum est marqué
par une abstention exceptionnelle.
Il y a 63 % d'abstention,
ce qui, à l'époque,
ne s'était jamais vu
dans aucune consultation,
mais 80 % de oui,
et ceux qui comptent,
c'est ceux qui votent.
Donc l'objectif a été atteint
et la paix civile a été restaurée
en Nouvelle-Calédonie.
-Les Français sont pas allés
énormément voter,
mais quand on voit aujourd'hui,
la crise géopolitique
se fait dans cet endroit du monde,
donc c'était finalement
un référendum
dont on n'a peut-être pas saisi
toute la portée sur le moment.
Musique majestueuse
Tic-tac d'horloge
...
-Mes chers compatriotes,
j'ai signé ce matin
le décret qui soumet à vos suffrages
le traité d'Union européenne,
ou traité de Maastricht.
-Le traité de Maastricht,
il crée d'abord
quelque chose de nouveau,
l'Union européenne,
qui va modifier
l'architecture
des traités européens.
-Et il se dit qu'on va abandonner
la monnaie nationale,
que c'est une grande étape
de la construction européenne :
il faut y associer le peuple.
-Ce qui compte,
c'est la campagne référendaire.
Celle-ci a été très intéressante.
On pensait au début que les Français
allaient pas du tout s'intéresser,
et finalement,
c'est devenu un débat passionné.
Les Français s'intéressaient
à l'Europe.
-Nous avons tous ressenti ça,
en particulier
au grand débat de la Sorbonne,
spectaculaire.
"Ode à la joie",
Beethoven
...
-Asseyez-vous.
-C'était un événement
médiatiquement exceptionnel.
-Je vous présente pas
la France...
-On avait rarement vu un président,
d'abord devant
4 ou 5 Français,
je sais pas combien.
Il s'est exprimé longuement
avec eux.
-Bonsoir, Roger.
Vous avez quel âge ?
-J'ai 62 ans,
je suis receveur des postes.
Je suis gaulliste.
-Et vous allez voter quoi, Roger ?
-En gaulliste, je voterai non.
-Dans l'harmonisation
européenne,
comment l'Etat pourra se priver
de la manne ?
Qui va payer ?
-Pour la France, vous ne pouvez pas
nous laisser mourir.
-La Communauté
soutient l'agriculture.
Le 20 septembre,
ce sera pas la fin de ce combat,
ce sera le début.
-C'est un homme galvanisé
par la conviction qu'il y a un enjeu
important pour l'avenir
et pour lui-même aussi,
parce qu'il faut pas oublier
qu'à partir du tournant de 1983,
l'Europe, c'est quand même
son principal projet,
puisque le reste, au fond,
s'est un peu fracassé.
-Et François Mitterrand le savait,
dès l'époque.
Il savait que c'était la fin
et qu'il fallait certainement
contribuer, j'allais dire,
à réussir sa sortie,
à sculpter son image.
-Il est très affaibli politiquement.
La droite va remporter un triomphe
aux législatives de 93.
Il veut prendre
une grande initiative politique
pour montrer que son pouvoir
n'est pas entamé.
-Vous savez que beaucoup de gens
vous accusent
d'avoir évité la voie parlementaire,
qui paraissait simple,
une ratification simple,
pour transformer ce référendum
en une sorte
de plébiscite personnel,
mais aussi en bon moyen
de diviser l'opposition.
-Ecoutez-moi, écoutez-moi.
Un plébiscite, soyons sérieux !
C'est l'Europe qu'il faut maintenant
plébisciter, si j'ose dire,
que j'aimerais voir plébiscitée.
-Il jouait extrêmement gros :
s'il échouait à cet égard,
cette volonté qu'il avait eue
d'être un homme européen,
de construire l'Europe,
c'était une dominante
de sa vie politique toute entière,
et il concentrait ses efforts
à ce moment-là
sur cette finalité.
-C'est dit par l'Elysée :
il veut ce référendum
pour qu'il y ait un lien
entre les Français
et cette puissance mal comprise
qu'est l'Europe.
C'est le grand dessein
de François Mitterrand,
mais il y en a aussi un petit,
qui est de diviser la droite.
-Hier soir,
sans jamais le nommer,
Chirac a reproché à Pasqua
de mélanger enjeux européens
et arrière-pensées
de politique intérieure.
-J'ai décidé de voter oui
en toute lucidité,
sans enthousiasme,
mais sans état d'âme.
-Alors, il vote oui,
et moi, je vote non.
-Jacques Chirac décide de soutenir
ce référendum
et Philippe Séguin
et Charles Pasqua
sont dans le camp du non
et, quelque part,
décident de devenir
un peu les souverainistes.
-Il a parlé longtemps,
très longtemps, Philippe Séguin :
2 heures 30
de réquisitoire anti-Maastricht,
devant une Assemblée nombreuse
pour une 2e partie de soirée.
-L'Europe qu'on nous propose
n'est ni libre, ni juste,
ni efficace.
est littéralement
l'anti-1789.
Applaudissements
...
"Ode à la joie",
Beethoven
Bonsoir.
-Bonsoir.
-M. le président de la République,
M. le ministre...
-Il voulait Séguin, sûr,
et pas Philippe de Villiers,
par exemple.
C'était une façon, pour lui,
de s'engager et de montrer
qu'il n'avait peur de rien,
de son opposition.
-Il y a beaucoup de Français
qui sont acquis
à l'idée européenne,
et qui ne peuvent accepter
ce traité de Maastricht.
-C'est votre cas ?
-Probablement,
oui.
seulement ?
-Plus
que probablement !
-Je me pose la question.
-Il y a eu un côté
- ne soyons pas excessifs -
un peu shakespearien,
dans ces moments-là,
puisqu'on savait
que Mitterrand était malade.
-Pendant l'enregistrement,
il devait subir des soins.
Evidemment, les téléspectateurs
ne le voient pas.
On a eu ce subterfuge
pour que ça n'apparaisse pas.
-Une partie des partisans du non
trouvait que Séguin était trop poli
avec le président
et qu'il était trop respectueux.
-Je me réserve,
M. le président de la République,
jusqu'à la fin de notre discussion,
et ç'aurait été irrévérencieux,
vis-à-vis de vous,
de conclure trop tôt.
-Lui dit qu'il avait été
très handicapé
dans l'attaque, à l'idée,
justement,
de s'en prendre
à quelqu'un d'aussi malade.
-Je souhaite que la France
ne limite pas sa diplomatie
au passage obligé
par la communauté.
-Lors de ce débat, on comprend bien
qu'il y a un vrai débat,
sur le fond, intellectuel,
passionnant !
Philippe Séguin n'est pas médiocre,
on peut être d'accord ou pas
avec ses arguments,
mais il se passe quelque chose.
Les Français sont fiers
de leur dispute.
Nous avons tous - j'y étais -,
nous avons tous ressenti
que se jouait là
quelque chose d'essentiel,
pour Mitterrand, son image,
pour la France
et pour l'Europe.
-Le traité de Maastricht
le permettra.
Je vous remercie.
-Je n'en ai pas la même lecture,
M. le président.
-Les arguments,
du coup, ont été
de très haut niveau,
dans cette période.
Et c'est ça qui doit rester
dans des campagnes électorales,
c'est ce qu'on souhaite :
que les arguments soient
au niveau des enjeux,
et je crois que le débat
de septembre,
de début septembre 1992,
à 17 jours du referendum,
étaient de ce niveau-là.
*-Le président se rétablit
normalement, dit-on,
de l'opération qu'il a subie,
il y a 5 jours.
*-Il devrait quitter Cochin
aujourd'hui
et reprendre ses activités
après une brève convalescence.
*-Un président applaudi
et souriant.
-Je souhaite très vivement
que les Français,
dans leur majorité,
optent pour le oui.
Parce que, pour moi,
dans mon esprit, dans ma conviction,
le sort de la France ne peut
que s'en trouver grandi.
-Les Français sont allés voter
pour ce débat aride,
parce que des hommes d'Etat, qui ont
prouvé qu'ils avaient le niveau
pour une dispute intellectuelle
de haut niveau
leur ont donné envie
de se positionner
sur un débat très aride.
Musique douce
...
-Le oui ne l'emporte
que d'extrême justesse :
51 % de oui,
49 % de non.
-Mitterrand,
qui était un combattant,
jusqu'au dernier moment,
aurait aimé
que ce soit plutôt à 54-55 %,
Mais il se réjouit
de ce dernier grand combat politique
qu'il a gagné.
Musique intrigante
...
-Cette réforme du quinquennat,
c'est un référendum sous contrainte.
Il est à part ce référendum,
parce que c'est un référendum
dont Jacques Chirac
n'avait pas envie.
-Voilà. Je reviens,
je vais prendre une photo
avec les Marocains. Je reviens.
Ce quinquennat,
sous une forme ou sous une autre,
serait une erreur.
Et donc, je ne l'approuverai pas.
-Il a toujours pensé
que le septennat faisait partie
de la Constitution gaullienne.
Il a toujours fait partie
des gens qui ont pensé
qu'il fallait, justement, faire
un septennat pour que le président
soit dominant par rapport
à une majorité
qui pouvait changer.
-On est en cohabitation.
Le Premier ministre de l'époque,
Lionel Jospin,
a fait savoir qu'il était plutôt
favorable à une proposition
de Valéry Giscard d'Estaing.
*-Valéry Giscard d'Estaing
relance spectaculairement le débat
en posant une question
-Et elle porte
sur la réforme du quinquennat.
-Giscard veut faire le quinquennat.
C'est une obsession, chez lui,
Jospin souhaite cette réforme.
-J'ai indiqué au président
de la République
qu'il était souhaitable d'engager
rapidement cette réforme,
afin qu'elle soit définitivement
adoptée avant la fin de cette année.
-Ce qui est sûr,
c'est qu'il s'est créé un climat
où on a fini par se persuader
que cinq ans,
c'était plus démocratique
que sept ans.
-Et à partir du moment
où il s'est dit :
"Jospin veut un quinquennat,
Giscard veut un quinquennat,
"Je ne vais pas m'empoisonner
avec ces gens-là !"
-Jacques Chirac ne veut pas
se fragiliser
et Jacques Chirac, là-dessus,
va agir avec pragmatisme.
-J'ai décidé
d'appeler les Français
à se prononcer
par la voie du référendum
sur la réduction
de la durée du mandat présidentiel
-En reprenant ce référendum
à son compte,
il s'empare du débat.
L'idée, c'est de ne pas subir.
-Alors le risque,
ce sera pas le non.
Ce ne sera pas le non.
Mais ce sera
le taux d'abstention record
à un référendum.
En effet, les Français
ne se sentiront
absolument pas concernés
par cette réforme du quinquennat,
qui est pourtant une réforme
bigrement importante.
-Il y a eu l'inversion du calendrier
dans la foulée,
pour mettre les législatives
après la présidentielle,
et cet enchaînement
ne fait
que confirmer
le scrutin présidentiel.
-On ne s'est pas rendu compte
des conséquences
qu'aurait le quinquennat
sur la vie politique française :
l'hyperprésidentialisation,
la question
de l'inversion du calendrier,
avec une majorité parlementaire
quasi automatique,
après l'élection présidentielle,
l'impossibilité
d'une cohabitation.
Les politiques
n'aiment pas la cohabitation,
mais c'est comme le référendum :
ça permet un moment
de disputes canalisées.
-Ca va avec un affaiblissement
de la démocratie représentative,
du Parlement,
par le fait
que le mandat parlementaire
et le mandat présidentiel
coïncident.
S'il y a un conflit,
il ne peut plus se résoudre
que dans la rue.
D'ailleurs, c'est un peu
ce qu'on a vu récemment.
-Le quinquennat a modifié
les institutions
de la Ve République,
la relation entre le président
et le Premier ministre,
et la façon dont les Français
jugent le rôle du président,
qu'ils considèrent maintenant
comme une sorte, parfois,
de super Premier ministre
qui s'occupe de tout.
-Il y a eu presque forcément...
une certaine présidentialisation
du système,
non pas au sens américain du terme,
puisqu'il demeurait
un Premier ministre responsable,
mais une concentration
du pouvoir
- cinq ans, c'est si court -
dans la personne
du chef de l'Etat.
-On est sur des sur des tons
qui, ajoutés à l'esprit du temps
et à la rapidité des moyens
de communication, etc.,
font que la vie politique
s'est considérablement rétrécie,
depuis le quinquennat.
*-Des six pays fondateurs,
l'UE est passée à 25 membres.
*-La Constitution doit organiser
un nouveau fonctionnement,
face aux besoins de sécurité
et d'emploi.
*-Juridiquement,
c'est un traité entre Etats
qui ne remplace pas
les constitutions nationales,
mais il ressemble
à une constitution.
-Ce référendum,
il a d'abord été une campagne
extraordinairement forte,
qui a marqué l'affaiblissement
des partis politiques.
-Souvenons-nous de cette campagne :
à peu près tous les observateurs,
tous les intellectuels,
tous les journalistes,
toute la classe politique
la plus visible,
étaient en faveur du oui.
*-L'Union pour un Mouvement
Populaire a une position,
et elle le dit aux Français :
c'est le oui !
Applaudissements
*-Je considère que le oui
fait avancer.
Je considère que c'est le oui
qui porte de nouvelles espérance
de traité.
-Le Parti Socialiste
est pour le oui,
l'UMP est pour le oui.
Evidemment.
Ce sont les deux grands partis,
Mais c'est considéré
comme, précisément, très choquant,
ce mélange de la droite
et de la gauche dans le oui,
-L'UMP, le PS,
le balancier,
la droite, la gauche
qui se font la courte échelle
finalement, ça a nourri
toutes les critiques antisystème.
*-Il y a 37 ans,
il était évacué de force
de la Sorbonne.
Aujourd'hui,
Daniel Cohn-Bendit, y revenait
un ministre, de droite,
pour défendre
la Constitution européenne,
-T'es vraiment passé
dans le camp du pouvoir !
Bravo, Dany !
T'as bien réussi !
Mais non, je ne veux plus t'entendre
maintenant !
-Ca donnait l'impression
aux citoyens
que les choses
se décidaient sans eux.
"On a décidé et on pense mieux."
-La campagne référendaire
du référendum de 2005
a, au-delà même d'une déconnexion
entre l'opinion et les élites,
je crois,
révélé vraiment une fracture
entre deux générations.
-L'Europe face à la Chine,
face au monde,
et là, un témoignage
et une question.
-De plus en plus
d'entreprises françaises
se délocalisent à l'étranger,
notamment l'industrie textile :
en quoi la Constitution
va nous aider
à ne pas perdre nos emplois ?
-Je voudrais d'abord
simplement rappeler
que... un principe simple :
c'est que l'union fait la force.
-Jacques Chirac
sous-estime l'usure par rapport
à Jacques Chirac lui-même.
Et c'est un Jacques Chirac
- on le voit dans le débat
avec les jeunes -
qui a perdu la main.
-C'est le débat de Jacques Chirac
avec les jeunes
qui reste le modèle absolu
de l'effondrement
de la fonction présidentielle
tel qu'on a pu le voir.
Il faut dire aussi que Chirac
avait dû subir des questions
qui portaient sur tous les sujets,
sauf sur la Constitution européenne
et le traité.
Evidemment,
ça l'a légèrement désarçonné.
-Nous avons
une jeunesse, un peuple
qui a lieu d'être fier
d'être français.
Il peut
avoir l'ambition
d'être un conducteur
et qui risque de se mettre
à la remorque.
-Il y a des jeunes,
à la télévision...
"Je ne vous comprends plus."
-Et je vais vous dire
très franchement,
je ne le comprends pas,
et ça me fait de la peine.
-Il dit son chagrin aux jeunes,
qu'ils pensent de travers.
C'est à peu près ça,
le message de cet échange
avec les jeunes !
Voilà. Il ne fait même plus
le service minimum.
Et, quelque part,
il libère les forces
de l'anti-chiraquisme.
-C'est spectaculaire.
La campagne de 2005
va complètement dériver.
-Il y avait une espèce
de dramatisation
absolument incroyable,
des figures de l'ennemi
qui réapparaissaient :
le plombier polonais,
l'électricien roumain... D'ailleurs,
une xénophobie, qui n'était pas
le propre de la droite de la droite,
mais aussi de la gauche
de la gauche !
-NON, NON, NON,
POUR LA CONSTITUTION !
NON, NON, NON,
-Beaucoup des maux qui ont été
identifiés, en 2005,
comme des maux européens,
le déficit démocratique,
le caractère trop technocratique,
la déconnexion
avec les attentes de l'opinion,
une législation européenne
qui va beaucoup trop dans le détail,
préoccupée des chenilles
des tracteurs
plus que des problèmes,
finalement, ce sont des critiques
que, depuis 2005,
on fait sans arrêt à l'égard
des institutions nationales.
-Les Français sont
pas anti-européens,
mais avaient une autre idée
de l'Europe.
On est au Conseil constitutionnel,
mais on se souvient
de la position courageuse
de Laurent Fabius, à l'époque au PS,
qui était pour le non à
ce traité constitutionnel européen.
-En répondant non, ça permettra
de réouvrir le dialogue.
C'est pas du tout...
Les murs ne vont pas s'effondrer !
On va rediscuter, pour aboutir
à une meilleure constitution,
pour avoir une Europe puissante
et solidaire.
-Il y avait aussi,
dans ce débat préréférendaire,
une petite musique utilisée
par les adversaires
de la Constitution européenne
disant : "De toute façon
"ne vous inquiétez pas, vous pouvez
dire non sans crainte au référendum,
"puisque, de toute façon,
"il y a un plan B dans les cartons
qui sera sorti."
-Bonsoir.
*-Valéry Giscard d'Estaing
fait campagne pour le oui,
mais à sa manière.
Il dit ne pas vouloir entrer
dans l'arène politique,
mais faire une explication
du texte qu'il a supervisé.
-On vous a dit :
"Il y a un plan B."
-Il était presque le père
de cette Constitution :
Il a présidé la convention
qui l'a rédigée.
*-Ce plan B,
c'est une blague.
Il n'existe pas.
-Et donc,
cet argument du plan B
n'était pas sérieux,
pour les défenseurs
du modèle européen :
ils n'imaginaient pas
que l'opinion pense,
après un tel travail
de rédaction d'une constitution,
que l'on avait pris soin
de garder dans les cartons
des formules alternatives,
qui pourraient être réutilisées,
si, ô stupeur,
les Français disaient non.
-Monsieur Bayrou.
S'il vous plaît.
Merci.
-Allez, c'est bon.
-A voté.
Musique douce
...
-Nous avons le choc
du non,
au référendum de 2005,
qui a construit
un autre clivage politique
que le clivage classique :
c'est un clivage
"le peuple contre les élites",
qui fait que le référendum
est un peu perçu
comme une machine
à fabriquer du non.
-Il y a cette volonté,
de plus en plus fréquente
dans la vie politique française
et de nos démocraties,
du vote protestataire,
du bras d'honneur
fait aux gens d'en haut.
Comme ça, globalement,
on fait un paquet cadeau
et on envoie un bras d'honneur.
-Peut-être que le refus
de ce référendum
est d'abord un refus
de l'unanimisme
de la classe politique française
et de la classe médiatique.
-Plus le diplôme s'élève,
plus le oui gagne,
plus le revenu est faible,
plus le nom est massif.
C'est une vraie coupure
entre la France populaire
et la France des élites
intellectuelles ou aisées.
La France aisée, Neuilly,
vote 80 % de oui,
mais le Pas-de-Calais
votera presque 70 % de non.
-TOUS ENSEMBLE TOUS ENSEMBLE
OUAIS OUAIS
-La France vous doit ce soir
la victoire.
Quant à l'autre,
qu'il se soumette !
-ON EST LA POUR FAIRE LES FOUS
-Moi, il me semblerait normal
qu'il démissionnât.
-Regardez où on en est aujourd'hui.
On n'a plus de bipolarisation,
on a une quadripolarisation,
certains disent même
un espace politique divisé en 5.
Et le désordre,
il est venu largement
par les référendums de 92 et de 2005
sur la question européenne.
Ca a engendré
une profonde turbulence politique.
-C'est le moment fondateur
de notre vie politique
depuis cette date.
-vous avez majoritairement rejeté
la Constitution européenne.
C'est votre décision souveraine,
et j'en prends acte.
-Un autre inconvénient
de l'échec du référendum de 2005,
c'est le traité de Lisbonne.
C'est-à-dire
que ce qui avait été rejeté
par le peuple,
a été, en gros,
repris par un traité adopté
par la voie parlementaire.
-Un point doit être souligné,
c'est que Nicolas Sarkozy,
élu président de la République
en 2007,
n'avait pas caché durant sa campagne
qu'il le ferait.
"Ode à la joie",
Beethoven
-Mini-traité
mais grand spectacle ce matin,
dans le prestigieux
monastère de Lisbonne.
-Sarkozy a ensuite décidé
de ratifier le traité de Lisbonne,
mais sans passer
par la voie référendaire.
C'est quelque chose
qui a marqué les Français.
Quelque chose s'est cassé.
-une partie importante
des Français
peut considérer
que leur non ne sert à rien,
si on fait rentrer par la fenêtre
ce qu'ils ont sorti par la porte.
-C'était pas anticonstitutionnel
ou contraire à la démocratie
mais ça a été ravageur.
Tic-tac d'horloge
Musique douce
-La classe politique française
reste assez traumatisée
par l'échec du référendum
de 2005.
Ce traumatisme est même sans doute
encore conforté par l'issue
du référendum britannique
sur le Brexit.
-Il y a maintenant la conviction
qu'à n'importe quelle
question posée,
les Français répondraient
par rapport au président
de la République
et au choix qu'ils ont
de le maintenir ou de s'en séparer.
-Pour, au fond, acclimater
le référendum,
il faudrait le déprésidentialiser,
que ça n'apparaisse pas
que comme une arme du président
et que donc les électeurs
aient davantage leur mot à dire.
-Il faut qu'il y ait davantage
de dialogue entre les citoyens
et le pouvoir politique.
Ca peut passer,
la convention citoyenne
en est un exemple,
par des assemblées citoyennes,
des tirages au sort,
des discussions,
des délibérations du Parlement,
rediscuter du texte de loi...
C'est le référendum
d'initiative partagée,
qui est prévu à l'article 11
de la Constitution
et qui n'a jamais été mis en oeuvre.
-Peut-être qu'un jour,
un candidat ou un homme politique
s'élèvera et viendra expliquer
très clairement
quelles sont les voies
pour faire un référendum "nouveau"
pour réconcilier
Français et politique.
-Le référendum ne manquera pas
d'être utilisé à nouveau.
C'est une pièce centrale
de la Ve République.
Reste évidemment à ceux
qui en ont la maîtrise à le manier
avec ductilité, avec finesse,
avec habileté
et avec efficacité, du point de vue
de l'intérêt général.
Musique douce
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA